As the global demand for white meat has grown in the US,...
...so, in turn has the size of our chickens.
In the last 50 years, the average weight of broiler chickens,...
...those raised for meat versus eggs, has roughly doubled,...
...while the time it takes for a chicken to mature has been cut in half.
In 1965, a 3.5-pound bird took 63 days to get to market.
In 2015, the average bird weighed 6.2 pounds in 48 days...
...though many companies are growing chickens ten pounds or larger.
But as the size of chickens has been increasing,...
...so has the prevalence of muscle disorders.
More chicken breast fillets are turning up laced with veins of fibrous meat...
...the industry has dubbed, "woody breast."
The condition doesn't present safety issues according to researchers,...
...but it is affecting quality and taste.
Scientists are still exploring the causes of the disorders,...
...but many suspect that growing heavier birds in a shorter time is part of the problem.